and thanks as always to the middle
presentation for making this evening
possible and I'm absolutely delighted to
welcome our two speakers tonight to
speak on what's really growing and I
think one of the most exciting field in
the humanities right now which is the
relation between cinema and philosophy
and how Sunnah in particular through the
work our two speakers have cinema new
media visual culture in general are free
were forcing philosophy to reconsider
some of its fundamental questions so the
format tonight will be our two speakers
so our two speakers IDI do hang is
associate professor of philosophy you
need us to give parents not that West
Mountain he also teaches at the finest
medical Zahav he's a former student of
economics agalya in the princeton
university and he served for a while
section of the french cultural services
here in new york
he's an author of several books one of
which is author and editor of the book
matrix mathematics machine he does if he
could came out in 2003 I guess and which
was fairly controversial but it's an
extremely smart book on the complex
commercial film maker because one of the
editors and one of the authors he is
also the editor of a volume of the
journal KT which came up in 2005 on
cinema and philosophy which is a great
great volume of fatigue 2005
with an article by and I bet you on
cinema as
and literally just an interview which
are calcium and a series of really
interesting as essays he is also
primarily but not only Burson scholars
legacy would cinema very well and
recently edited a critical edition of do
they pay Stevenson ATT and is publishing
a book on our second speaker at least
many VA is a lecturer in philosophy at
the University of Essex and has also
taught that lead and it's also graduated
economics entire dissertation he's the
author of a number of books on the
intersection between philosophy and
social sciences he also at least also
contributed to the matrix volume
and he has just published this book
which I'm just delighted to have my hand
Fugazi enough and I also want to mention
before turning things over to books that
our two guests just published in the
collection the pack suit which seems to
be a great collection these are two
absolutely fantastic books which I had
the great pleasure of reading one is
full half of that go easy stuff dizzy
manage maybe giving on the coexistence
of images in the form of split screens
in the form of montage temporal
disjunction and also our existence our
coexistence with images at Eastman
publish that must be keep you jab the
devil's perspective or the devil's point
of view which I just
and the book as well which is a way to
rethink the relation between thought and
image not necessarily from Satan's point
of view although that comes in but also
focusing on an is an art installation by
the two biggest tools which are this who
recreated the apartment of Rose Marie
and guy Woodhouse in Rosemary's Baby and
the installation was called Rosemary's
play and this is the starting point of
an amazing of theses amazing reflection
cinema or visual culture
so welcome and
so I'm going to present you something on
well on the book which will mention I
just want to thank the visual process
and you going
liking us here today we all liked it to
be here and I hope you shed pleasure
well I'm just going to say sorry for my
accident creation and this probably
sometimes work okay so I still think
there's been a lot of physical interest
of movie movies lately but too often I
think the other percent you relates to
films just as ministrations of already
given philosophical ideas so we can find
in the matrix exactly Plato's cave or
you could buy in hitch got everything
you always wanted to be about lack of a
visible so that which you check it once
say well this is a bit unsatisfying to
us and in fact our question in E and I
we share that me think we also be
mythological approach our questions
recent
is it is it possible to be better than
that is to find instance things which
theory of nullity has not already
offered so our answer and surprisingly
is yes and I hope we will be convincing
so one way to do that would be to start
with products and that's what the way we
suggest we work don't tell anybody but
it's a delusion methodology so we think
that we need to start with problems with
philosophical products and then we think
that you can find in different practices
not philosophical practices visual
practices raises problems which are and
illogical but the different treaty needs
of the same father okay
and so the our question is whether if we
pay attention the clearest attention to
the way the problem is treated for
instance in cinema we could reel a beret
tan maybe displace the philosophical
problems which we have okay so that's
the way we work and that's why I think
we are here just mainly to give an
example
so more recently I finished this book
which they'll mention with a colleague
of mine dr. Bob Young where we try to
approach the relation between Foucault
and Sienna so why should cook well good
disciple who could enlighten us that's
the great thing with Foucault that I
absolutely no interest in CMC literature
in painting music we had a lot various
interest but cinema was not among them
in fact it was approached by authorities
and starting from the Kenyatta cinema
and he replied to these people asking
him interviews it's also because you
have the impression that they have
concerts in their own fields which
resonated with his own problems as a
historian and as a philosopher so
basically one of these main questions
was with the possibility of having a non
ideological relation to history history
is very often a way by which we hybrid
ideologically relates to our home self
because it's guided by the question how
did we become who we are
and for this question a radical shift in
the approach to history that's what he
does in his philosophical and historical
practice he says that we should do
history will turn to the past not in
order to have a more accurate view of
what is no more and not also in order to
explain the present but on the country
in order to get a stronger stance of the
contingency of situation so not to
explain why we have become what we are
now not to find a necessity behind all
that but on the contrary to find a
better sense of things that could be
different and that will maybe can be
changed so history is for Foucault an
instrument to extraction
but because it relates to align the line
great to be married with someone that is
strange as beautiful things you have to
have relation to yourself so what he
meant by that in that he wanted us to
have a sense of the contingency of what
we take for granted so all the absolute
things which we think are unavoidable
should be reworked and appear as merely
contingent so for instance we think that
everybody has always had a sexuality in
that society's a dimension of the human
life and that for the job of someone who
do the history of sexuality would simply
be to Alice what happy what the sexual
behaviors of the past that be and what
the reception may be about sex happy but
Foucault disapproves of these approaches
to a society and for him to do the
history of sex on to consist in showing
that the very notion of the great
problem is nothing necessary or or
absolute so it's not that sexuality has
changed right it's that we must define
sexuality by a series of changes which
constituted
as a prophet as another so that means
that the very notion of sexuality must
become a variant so just one possibility
of something which could be otherwise
and must be defined in the field of
other things which is to see right the
friction could be the Greek the Greeks
aphrodesia or the Roman care of the self
or the Christian possible techniques I
mean these different things was helped
to relate to ourselves in the
differential way to reduce our own
present to all the differences which
they present with these other fools of
ourselves so the beauty of that is that
instead of looking at the past and the
present the full of present situation
present situation which is no more he
wants to look at the present as a cure
variation something which is already
defined as a variation right so that's
that's why
so not to define the president as
something that changes but to define the
president as the variation in itself so
very often I think we don't we can feel
what it means to have a very radical
historical approach to everything right
but we usually don't realize how very
cool this ship must be and that's what I
would like to emphasize now basically
means that there is nothing underneath
that changes there is nothing underneath
the changes that changes agree that what
we are what there is everyone would be
nothing but changes so the job of the
historian would be to deconstruct the
illusion of any sort of underlying
identity and to reduce everything to the
full of variation that it is so it's the
critical work in the center which
reduces everything something else than
what it appears to be it reduces
everything to think which are defined by
correlation of differences but there
so it's a very under political relation
to history in the sense of what
apologists do they relate to others in
order to redefine us as others among
others as one say okay if I if something
things which don't make sense to be
right make faces
okay now this I did decided that there
is that thing but rather that there are
changes but nothing that changes
underneath this idea actually
and it's like it's a very odd idea which
goes against our normal way of thinking
so what I'm saying here that cuckoos
practice of history committing to a
particular philosophical conception of
the world which sometimes not but not
always doesn't feel the need to do so
and these conception of the world
basically say that the world's main
events now of course you would probably
recognize here also some claim made by
the best but the interesting fact here
is that also one of his life without the
need to turn to cinema in order to
understand better what and do some
cinema is quite soon
with difficult to follow many tales but
the general idea is very simple safe
cinema is the art of extracting pure is
best you'll be coming from current
situations so to reduce everything
respect to that potential to become from
right so that's an interesting battle
for an interesting idea because it may
mean that we can find in the way cinema
has approached historical problems
something which will indeed resonate
with through good historical practice
there is an intention just been
encountered so can we learn anything
about the nature of historical events if
we look at the way cinema has approached
history but basically my general
question in the book so I'm just going
to give you one example which
dresses of the weight sitting that can
help the three was in the concept of
events which we don't find already made
in photography it's the example is not
and fog by aligning
it's not my fault it's that history
sometimes very violent so why they
stopped well precisely because it shares
the same concerns as concurs
why because processions of documentary
film or the historical events the event
which aims at disturbing the relation
between the past and the present which
organizes our notion of history oddly
enough in fact maybe that's not enough
State the film is not made in order to
fight against forgetting in fact the
film relates to the past not as
something which has orchard in a
different location in the normal time
but on the country as something which is
an ever-present virtuality of our
current situation
so basically wants to disturb the
relation between the present and the
past but if the that was just something
far into and say well no you must relate
to the past as a virtual dimension of
your
it shows something about what you are
but as an effect also it means that our
present is nothing but precisely one
virtual possibility okay so in fact it
makes makes it very clearly in an
interview which he gave to you Richard
Ruskin
actually I think it's not written in
English but he's there I define it so if
any whenever I think about that it would
be very helpful to me
see so that's what he says I had this
idea of interrogation question yes
that's what it is
I wouldn't film which say to people not
don't forget I wasn't interested in that
but trying to understand why that
happens or rather don't wait for it to
be happens that happened in order to
care that it I spoke after the earth
well to say that in English actually
it's the net that out emergency and it
was the terror that it may start the
game it was indeed a huge its relation
to question much
so in other words the point of this
historical film is not to teach us
anything about the past but rather to
make our present itself more problematic
to our minds to unsettle our relation to
ourself now so the math disturbing I
have the relation to that the present
it's not that is something which moved
no which can't be nerman actually so
it's a strange reversal actually if you
think about it in the notion of
historical knowledge it's so you have a
very clear example of that in the final
scene maybe if I have time actually it's
true in some of these where you have the
room of the cabinet I think it's a block
which is the gas chamber
and you'd say that it is a strange
observatory and in fact it means that
these images which you will see and are
not meant to be see for themselves that
meant to displace we had in mind the
colonial war against other people you
the suspected that was about the caste
in the Soviet Union but actually doesn't
matter too much in the center the point
is more general than that I think and we
can still think about it
example so the point is that we
communicate with the past not as with a
distant object but with as we the
possibility of ourselves right so I
think you see how it resonates to say
it's a critical relation to the present
as an objective attempt a defining
motion now the question is I'm just
going - Allah and the question would be
what are the cinematic techniques that
painting uses in order to convey this
intention I know but I don't know yet
any words and can we learn anything
which may be of interest from these
techniques from the cinematic techniques
we really think about the nature of
historical knowledge recklessly I think
there are three major techniques
which conveyed this sense of the
critical relationship resolution math so
the first one consists in creating a
tension between the text and images
basically the text says you cannot have
a good sense of what we shared the text
predicts the images and a very
possibility of having the sense of ways
in the past in certain way so instead of
helping us to draw over the Gulf of time
the film increases makes it even harder
okay there are many things you say about
this this is property semantics right
it's owed your visual there is a
discrepancy there is a contradiction
between what is site and what is shown
and this tension is very interesting
something which could go the 17th was
also very anxious today and of course
obviously clutter you cannot do
visual one troupe tradition with death
well the second technique is the
juxtaposition of images in black and
white on one hand from the archives and
images in colors which are shot on on
the spot in the camps and the color
which is very because the color instead
of making these images more realistic
giving us a new sense of the reality of
these games in fact makes it even harder
for us to represent whether it's in fact
they split the image as if we couldn't
relate to what they were presenting
precisely to they uncovered there is a
beautiful night in the text but que hora
by junking order we say something to say
first in French and then I
sensation oddly enough that
in practice the seductive the bleach the
cement monastic movement technicals
lacunae so of this brick poetry of these
frightened seekers we can only show you
the shell and oddly enough the shadow so
the color is precisely what separates us
from the object it's not a better
representation of the country something
even move
in education in the present image of the
split which is open in the present
itself the fact that we cannot recite
with that has been the past
we are acceptable cannot believe we can
saw with these presents and the third
technique are these very famous
panoramic shots which in particular the
beginning and again have a point you
stream something you have the time
so like Bootsy it's a very funny scene
can we
there are bees that funky
never imperative article voting was hard
if you're damn
Mary University but usually based on
Teague Melanie - protocols everything
Valley and receivers come here to serve
the norm karkos of us
the street of parent group it's not in
canvas and others work that's fueled a
non-committal Ducati recited in a
position to developers mobility about in
Kalina indoor there but you see that
there is a little more for Sebastian a
the kimono must be non-physical
well so I think you have so but so I'm
interested in the fact that the relation
between the top of the present here is
conveyed with these cook existence it's
conveyed by a typical similar graphic
technique which is to bring in the field
that which is out of the field
so whatever what does he do it
well I suppose it could be idea that we
have a training and we must redefine the
president by what surrounds it out of
its own train so the president must be
defined our series and the film receives
like that by a series of reframing of
embedded reframing by which the identity
of the present that which we thought was
just you know peaceful landscape becomes
something else
raishin yeah so you have a horrible
which are constant and which you also
find in the film which in the relation
between in the so for instance you from
the when you are in the cast in the
village about there seems to be just
marriage are two things which are not
compatible it cannot be possible
together so to be who existent by the
camera by the tracking shot so that's
the way they made conveys a sense of
this virtual dimension so often present
do not success to one another they could
exist together in a virtual damage
well there are possibilities over now so
they are just like faces of the same
thing so of course it's very worried
it's very worried because it means that
we must define ourselves by everything
which happened something we must
redefine ourselves like everything which
has happened and the interesting shows
that the question of the park all the
reconsideration of prominent time has to
do when you try to approach this you
know with a way you will produce a
particular film in space
and that I think is true general
something which indeed it's very subtle
points but cannot let the shoe shoes for
me to presentation
so yes but in comparison to what you've
just heard my presentation will may
sound a bit sketchy the thing that I
want to do this job of extracting a
rather abrupt way underlying
metaphysical physicists we just alluded
to
regarding the coexistence of the virtual
and the actual the past and the present
and do it in a way that is still in
touch with the actual operations of
cinema in order to do this I will on the
one hand with you a few of the
metaphysical underpinnings of disease
and of course themselves relying heavily
obviously infections concepts of time
and duration
on the other hand I would like to
illustrate but in a less focused way
than Patrice these views by a series of
examples taken from I hope very diverse
domains cinema so the first thing I want
to submit is this quote by Duluth which
i think is very interesting quite
typical of his take on cinema the way
relations between I was a student of
philosophy extracted from an interview
that came out of published when the
first volume of is to came out says I
was a student of philosophy and although
I wasn't stupid and although it wasn't
stupid enough to want to create a
philosophy of cinema one conjunct
conjunction made an impression of I
liked those authors who do referring to
philosophical offers yes who demanded
that we introduce movement assault
remember they denounce the German
dialectic an abstract movement how could
I not discover the cinema which in turn
introduces real movement into the image
I wasn't trying to imply philosophy to
cinema but I went straight from
philosophy to cinema the reverse is also
true
one went right from cinema to philosophy
so there are really three things witches
emphasized here before going on its
first the idea that donors doesn't think
he was stupid enough as he says to
produce a philosophy of Cena the two
volumes entitled movement image and time
image are not books that we should
categorize as philosophy of cinema the
way he operates on cinema is not by
providing some kind of external
reflection on that thing we call cinema
those things we call films there is no
need in fact first year along this line
of thought there's no need for
philosophy and cinema does not need you
must be obviously but philosophy is not
even called for it's not even required
for cinema to make sense to be
understood there's a lot of writings
about cinema even before any philosopher
got interested into in cinema there is
there are very intelligent discourses on
cinema problems of cinema the essence of
cinema so basically
is not to say the truth about what
cinema is no philosophy awesome first
thing I wanted to stress the second year
is of course and it's a consequence of
the first there's no need to apply
philosophical ideas to cinema it it's
rather do the as you said rather the
opposite move which is interesting for
to notice how you not to extract
something from cinema rather than apply
ready-made ideas or philosophy as we say
in French pieces of ready-made
philosophy it's rather to extract
concepts from cinema in order to do more
velocity along different lines product
and finally the idea that this operation
of this encounter is conjunction French
word I guess is the whole point of
conjunction says in a home for my
questioning I was impressed by certain
encounter the encounter between cinema
and philosophy is one that doesn't need
any kind of mediation that's very
important to there's no need for a kind
of overlay of theoretical ideological
discourse on cinema
in order for philosophy to make
something obscene there is a kind of
direct short-circuit with costly the
take and actually when you read to do
this is work although it's a very
informed and he obviously has read a lot
making even more than having seen many
films he has read a lot many books many
articles on cinema critical
despite this mass of information it's
very obvious that for Judaism philosophy
doesn't need much mediation as a kind of
directed take and the way it works for
donors is as Patrice mentioned is that
well philosophers start with their own
problems and then kind of encounter
problems which are of the same kind you
have to see what that can mean in cinema
authors in cinema encounter problems
which kind of resonate with problems
that philosopher on their own health
encounter
are trying to elaborate so cinemas never
pretext for at the applying philosophy
it's really an extension of philosophy
or the way to do philosophy by other
means and the way it works is by
extracting concepts I've used this this
expression several times extracting
concepts concepts as Deleuze regularly
stresses is is property philosophy the
job of philosophers said he says to
construct to produce concept basically
that that's what defines in a very
operational way philosophy but if cinema
does not produce concepts for its own
sake and it produces ideas there are
ideas in cinema this big on cinema as
the recession rather odd way this type
of cinema which kind of resonate with
concepts but which come from this work
of extraction there are using some
language
which Express certain cinemates for
African problems and the Java for the
philosophies to extracted the concept
which adequately which are apt to
develop or unfold the problems which
these ideas these cinematographic ideas
express what concepts
what problems and what ideas and also
why I mean what's the end result with
the benefit of extracting concepts in
this strange encounter or in soon so the
general question why should not suffer
pay attention to cinema because there
are other domains that literature
science there are many ways to actually
do philosophy through other means
why cinema I would say that in fact
cinema share preserves the same benefits
as any other domain in that respect for
lastly the ID for another person
especially philosophers like Delors or
better in another way the benefit of
going through this detour is two games
precision to reach a level of precision
that philosophy by its own means can
never reach that was a basically
Bergson's principle basic very profound
principle he said that can also be need
precision and in fact in his view this
was the main reason why the philosopher
should study science or art or the human
sciences Social Sciences in order not so
not so much in order to understand
understand what's going on there to
provide a philosophy of this domain but
in order to to attain a level of
precision level of refinement that
context and sheer concepts by themselves
can never attain so I would say the
general answer to why philosophy is you
know why what can we expect from this
encounter is more precision
we try to not to give an example of the
kind of problems ideas concepts that we
can make more precise by by assembling
or by breeding philosophy and so I would
be what the nurse has in common person
is that is interested for reasons that I
don't have time to explain he's
interested in extracting an ocean of
pure mobility a notion of to be coming
out of the various forms the various
happenings that's one can witness in
one's experience he's interested in this
notion of mobility with that mobilize
without things actually moving
sheer fact of mobility issue near
phenomenon mobility and what he sees in
cinema is a direct expression of this
possibility of not only thinking but
also experiencing in a very obvious
straightforward way this pure mobility
which doesn't need to be attached to
careers mobiles or things that are
actually doing the movie sheer mobility
and of course this notion of sheer
mobility is best exemplified in the
technical operation of cinema which is
the tracking shot we have a nice example
of the track the opening shots of really
good job we could illustrate the same
principle of the tracking shot by this
famous scene from vertigo
there's actually a little more than
tracking shots in this scene I'm sorry
for the kind of stroboscopic effect it's
entirely due to the weakness of my
machine
really I'm showing this that I have to
come back to vertigo for obvious reasons
you have to do with relation between
past and present virtual nationals
but they're sure an example tracking
shot from this movie
but there's something is stupid we
should notice here
I think central hardware
I'm sorry
this
the inaugural seewer
James sheriff is supposed to meet or
even to see Madeleine Kim Novak here in
this scene where they can clearly
understand that there's no way you could
have actually seen her face to face
their eyes not meet again
do not cross this is the kind of
metaphor for the whole movie as a movie
about lines of actions which do not
adjust we which keep which keep which
are kept in a kind of disjunctive state
which never quite fit together the
importance of the tracking shots as far
as our question is concerned our problem
is concerned the problem why philosophy
should connect with cinema to make its
own problems we were specific more
precise this importance of the tracking
shots there is explains it due to the
fact that in the tracking shot we have
the example of
which is itself virtual there's an
actual continuous reframing that's the
principle of the track in showbiz
continuous reframing of the scene of the
field and at the same time in most of
them most of the tracking shows there's
no way you can clearly attach the
movement this movement of the camera to
any particular mobile moving element in
the scene you could project the ID that
this virtual movement this camera remove
is in fact substitute for the subjective
point of view of a particular character
here would be James Stewart and gazing
through the restaurant but in the most
general case and even here in that scene
it is clear that there's no there's no
clear correspondence between any
actually moving element in the scene and
the virtual movement of the camera so
the tracking shot by itself exemplifies
the idea pure mobility mobility has an
absolute quality that does not need any
vehicle any career so
conclusion of Delors in his brilliant
analysis of the tracking shot is that
cinema
does not simply put images into motion
but and down these images with kind of
stealth motion which is which is if you
wanted to define characterize cinema in
its essence which is the essence of
cinema all about and damning images with
the kind of stuff motion images as
movement rather rather than images often
and of course you know that the first
volume of the disease work on cinema is
called imagine movement image the second
is imaged on time image the tracking
shot and the long take the long take are
of course presence in both volumes but
you can see how the very definition of
the tracking shots led to those
inevitably to kind of
temporal characterization the tracker
shot rather than spatial the tracking
show it is related to the idea of sheer
ability is already virtually something
that opens up to a purely temporal
characterization of the basic operations
of cinema not only is it an example of
sort of infra or Supra human point of
view a point of view which is beyond all
views but as a virtual movement of the
camera itself it suggests something that
in fact exceeds all actual motion and
presents itself manifests itself as a
movement through time
really making it very short we're
putting very briefly but I think that's
the the essence of the tracking shop
being itself the basic operation of
cinema more important than framing which
it has in common with photography the
essence of the tracking shot is to
extract shreya mobility and project the
whole cinematographic experience into
time and now of course this suggests a
problem it's a problem that the Duluth
and country very soon in his books and
the problem is is there a movement of
the film itself the film as such does a
film eventually reduced to a two-hour
tracking shot speaking metaphorically
because there are very few film which
actually worked this way although there
are some experiments there's lines even
Tarkovsky using very few tapes
very long tails where time is kind of
distended to use it
dilated but most of the times well
editing comes into play and kind of
conjoins the powers of the cut with the
temporal the temporal expressive covers
of the tape
but still there is this notion of this
feeling that we could on a certain level
if we abstract from the immediate the
images perception and effects of relate
to each scene if we kind of take some
distance and consider the experience of
the film as a whole there is a certain
sense in which you want to say that
every film basically tends to this to
this idea of one single take one long
shot which would kind of provide the
virtual movement of the film itself
which would total eyes every moment and
give provide the essence of
cinematographic experience how basically
generalize this problem it comes down to
the question how does the film as at all
presents itself as a single unified
experience and it's not an easy question
when you think of it it's the fact of
sitting in front of the screen for two
or three even four hours doesn't make it
a single experience by itself it's the
question we should ask does it make
sense to step out to the theater after
one hour yesterday to the : Cooper's
gallery where you can see the amazing
video keys back Eastern Athletic on the
clock it's a 24-hour video piece you can
see the whole film on Friday nights I
guess into Saturday mornings we spent it
was really a very fulfilling experience
but of course we were kind of frustrated
too because obviously we haven't been
through the whole experience and I think
it's raised the question what a beyond
the question of narrative closure the
question
of getting to the end of the story in
terms of cinematographic experience
where does the unity of the film line
eventually we think of movies as
experiences
well here they would like to emphasize
the in dollars his own analysis
the tracking shot which was the starting
point of my presentation is in fact well
seems to be a very unstable operation
because on the one hand it's clearly
what unifies the action of the meaning
of a series of texture but at the same
time it is also what unleashes the power
is now it's a disruptive powers that are
virtually contained in the total fuel
space of the film
buzzer Andre Bazin used to say that the
tracking shot in that respect was the
negation of framing framing provides a
kind of totality although it leaves
things
we're having this discussion what is the
best translation option okay but still
it gives you a sense of closure but the
tracking shot being the continuous key
framing of the image is in fact
centrifugal it is a negation of framing
and it is what opens up the film the
entire film to a multiplicity of actions
that unfold simultaneously and from
which every tracking shot cuts this is
whether tracking shot does it's not only
reframing the image in real time it's
about catching through the multiplicity
of lines of action with their own
durations and providing a sense of unity
which is at the same time totally
centrifugal and I think this is a point
which is central it's a difficulty that
there is encounter us because there
and stability your attention between or
polarity between two dimensions of
cinema on the one hand the consistency's
delusion world systems the consistency
brought about by the tracking shot and
the notion of virtual movement and at
the same time the disruptive tendency of
any tracking shot to open up the
cinematic experience to a multiplicity
of diverging directions and this is of
course what is it's taken the most
accomplished examples of this art it's
about providing a sense of community
within the most multifarious the most
disruptive potentially disruptive
experience of a multiplicity of
durations
basically what I'm talking about here is
in fact a problem that relates to space
time and this is what I want
get out I've mostly been framing the
problem in terms of time because there
was following the threat suggested by
backs on the business interpretation of
Maxim have been following the threat of
time temporal threat but what I'm would
like to get at to get true is actually
an adequate characterization of the
cinematic problem the cinematic issue
that for philosophy in terms of
space-time space short and broad expanse
space-time well I won't be you all know
that there's a very obvious way in which
cinemas in fact actively constructing a
new experience of space-time by merely
merely streaming static images two
images together the way I requested the
wake chrono photography had already done
but with the parcel animating mechanism
which we know that this is in fact in
itself a kind of modernization of
space-time you may know that Death Zone
who is not very fond of cinema either
although he went to the movies but I
don't think there is enough to write a
book about the movies
Bergson used as you may know to say that
well this kingdom enter graphic this
kinematic graphic rendering of
space-time of spatial temporal
experience is in fact an adequate model
for the general illusions of
intelligence the way we cut things down
to static images in order to animate
them using relying on some kind of
abstract power of animation some kind of
abstract movements and eventually a
homogeneous timeline which would be the
kind of cereal the cereal
the scheme of things the way things
succeed each other
chronologically this for him was the
kind of spatial temporal model that
intelligence resorts to when it wants to
come to terms with becoming and for him
it had of course that you know a very
negative ring to it because the idea was
that not only this illusion could be
overcome and it should be overcome in
order to - for philosophy to actually
solve its own problems
well what I would like to suggest non
relying on a few example providing your
example is that this notion of
space-time could be reevaluated in a
more positive sense and maybe in a sense
which to do is while sometimes defining
things in terms of block discussed on
space 9 blocks was kind of wary about
the direction of talk that
it cuts across the Berk Sounion the
persona privilege of time over space and
in a way would like to provide the
positive the positive version of the
circles spatialization of time which
works on the master and this can be
understood in two ways and it's really
two very different kind of example
I'd like to introduce on the one hand
you could view the matter I know in an
intensive way stressing the temporal the
world temporal and spatial temporal
space-time and the other way would be
symmetrically to emphasize the spatial
component of space-time it's a more
extensive approach on the one hand and
this is vertical which will be helpful
here
you could kind of try and see how the
construction of a time image which is
ultimately what every film is getting as
according to de leurs the virtual
tendency of any film is to to reach some
kind the equivalent of the time image
it's not something that is
reserved for certain films or a certain
period of cinema two-week do this
closely there's no clear-cut a position
between one kind of cinema and the other
it's a rather question of tendencies as
always so this is the first line of
examples particular who has example an
intensive take on spatial temporal
experience and on the other hand will
rely on a very different example which
is a series 24
which is a very nice example of the way
cinema or television but at this point
the limits between the two are blurred I
think and not very interesting in fact
the way cinema or television that
actively produces a new kind of space
time in which the time image to diligent
argument develops according to new
dimensions can be unfolded among new
dimensions so very quickly and it's just
another way of putting it so I don't be
too normal this the problem space time
is basically a problem of coexistence
the world with introduced by at least
the coexistence of the past in the
present as a way to go beyond the merely
chronological serial linear conception
of time the succession
moments faces co-existence introduces
the complimentary
the complementary idea of things
actually and falling through time by
coexisting and again this can have to
Nene for existence and referred as the
coexistence of past and present the fact
that the present does not succeed the
past but kind of carries the past along
with it or it can be understood
extensively the coexistence of duration
spread out in space the question of how
different lines of actions lines of
duration can be part of a single whole a
single experience but the two aspects
are really I think essential components
of this cinematic experience there are
two problems that we have to solve as
philosophers because they touch on the
most I would say the most basic concepts
that we need in order to understand the
way things hang together in the most
general sense of the term I like the
definition provided by an analytic
philosopher called feel fruit sellers
used to say that philosophy is really
enough
I would say metaphysics is really about
understanding how things in the most
general sense of the term hang together
in the most general sense of the term
coexistence is one word that has been
running through the history of
philosophy in Latin sometimes with Nexus
Nexus is the word which has been running
through this short history of philosophy
to capture this problem of how things
hang together in space and time
okay there is in the same interview says
the following in a way sums up
everything I've said so far it seems
obvious to me that the image is not in
the present but the image represents is
in the present but not the image itself
the image itself is a mishap in the
sample of time away from the present
which merely flows either as a common
article or at the smallest divisor
relations of time are never seen in
ordinary
but they are seen in the image as long
as it's in the creative one in its
renders time relations relations that
can't be reduced to the present sensible
and visible for example an image shows a
man walking along along a riverbank in a
mountain region in this image there are
at least three coexistence durations
three rhythms the relation of time is
the coexistence of durations in the
image which has nothing to do with the
present that is what the image
represents the concept of the image in
the presence only applies to mediocre or
commercial images I think these kind of
sums of the two books regulars
eventually very it's a very simple
problem but understanding that when is
it important about cinema is not the
feeling of the present what is presented
to you because the image which is
ultimately essential confirm
never present never given in the present
it may represent things happening now
but this is really pretext
what makes a film what makes the movie
the movie is the way images are
presented to you in a very odd way in
the sense that they're never actually
only present but always presented to you
at the same time has past or maybe as
future to be the image is the Nexus of
time relations in the way that it
describes things very simple example
which is an allusion to famous
Australian example involving birds and a
river exactly the same problem very
simple example shows that it is at the
same time question of space enough time
the question of space and time because
the problem ultimately is about the
coexistence of durations rhythms not
only in your conscious but also in the
world which the image represents in the
space which the film constructs
as you know I refer to this earlier
bowing to disease own orientation
philosophical orientation is Burke Sonya
origins you might say this analysis
converges towards this notion of the
time image which is the modality regime
of the cinematic image which captures
sentence taken from first a little time
in its pure state after the tone I'll
eat a tree so there are many examples of
this but the most striking those which
are the purest example in de luces you
are example that when he calls
image a star crystal images so why a
crystal and how whether the criteria to
identify crystal diamond well there are
no criteria that's an interesting fact
there is no way you can actually point
at an image in a film and say oh there
it is I have this image crystal which
actually captures a little time in its
purest state that is that
an image which would present itself as
this shear Nexus of time for space-time
relations without ever without a
recrystallizing or reducing to an actual
state or an actual mental state given to
the consciousness of the spectator
there's no way you can identify certain
images as
Tristan images as opposed to other
images which would not be crystallized
or lacking something essential now you
might say having residue is that this is
not really true because he gives
examples but the point is these examples
are very troubling the thing to have to
understand is that there's a scheme a
kind of philosophical scheme behind his
definition of the crystal image
it's explicit I'm not guessing here this
is very easy to about the fact that the
philosophical scheme of this concept of
Krishna images taken from article
reproducing mind energy Volume Mascara
translated as mind energy which works
and is trying to pathological cases of
Paramecium
the feeling of deja view which is
sometimes can become very very intrusive
and quite pathological instead with
certain persons having kind of constant
feeling of desire which and strangest
them radically from experience in their
relationship how does it work well why
is it why I'm not gonna explain when is
it's taking person but the essential
point here is that in the feeling of
desire the way braixen interprets it you
have a kind of super impression overlay
of the present the actual presence the
image you get by simply perceiving
things and the memory of this present
not the memory
the memory that will be brought back by
this perception and memory from
something that happened to you in the
past no the memory of this present that
you're actually experiencing which is
kind of given simultaneously with the
actual perception so the interpretation
of the souvenir depends on the teacher
who the paramecia according to Bergson
the right interpretation is to
understand that here we have an instance
of the coexistence of the presence of
the actual perception and the immediate
memory of this perception so that the
perception is actually present itself in
this kind of spectral eerie dimension of
being at once the present that it is and
the past that it already is - the past
is it's an instance where the past is
very a very course elusive but in most
cases but it's an instance of the past
coexisting in a very literal way with
the present the past fear is simply a
dimension of the present experience it's
not something that happened to you
before it's what's happening now in the
direction of the past because the past
again it's not a dimension that it's not
an archive of whatever happened it's not
the a combination of past present the
past is actively present as coexistent
dimension of experience which relates to
whether as we say more mental on or
metaphysical level so what does do is
extract from this it's a double
operation of extraction he has to
extract something from a person on the
one hand and extract something from
cinema from Burton extract the mere idea
the coexistence or a super impression of
the virtual past and the virtual memory
of the present and the actual perception
of the present the coexistence of
virtual and actual past and present
memory and perception but they are given
in a state of coalescence or fusion
fusion and this is what he needs what
the race needs to understand the
fundamental operation of cinema the fact
that the virtual movement of the camera
the image as a temporal as a movement
through time even as a movement through
time
in fact constantly aims at providing
this kind of experience although it
doesn't always reach that goal it's
always aimed at providing an experience
where the actual and virtual are sort of
fused together
in one single experience the president
being at once something that you can
understand that the perspective of the
past or the present being also in itself
the reminiscence of something that has
not yet happened so the examples because
that was my starting point how can we
identify such moments such Tristan
images you understand the metaphor of
the crystal and I didn't read that the
metaphor because it's a metaphor the
crystal comes from the fact that a
crystal actually presents itself as a
very translucent piece piece of matter
which which kind of
which displays the virtual image of
certain circumstances light his rights
presidents a virtual image in these
times of when sometimes referred to as
total refraction a virtual image that is
seems to be floating in the middle of
the of the crystal and which is kind of
contemporary with the actual reflection
of the environment on it's a different
size the image in de luces the waiter
that is using it is the reduces to the
notion of the two-faced two-sided image
one side is in the virtual the other
side is in the actual one side is
actually perceived the other is given in
the element of pure pure memory this is
what is crystal like running examples he
gives because he gives examples are very
strikes are very I would say disturbing
unsettling he refers in many places to
this famous scene from
the Canadians are distinguished in both
mirror mirror here why don't you try
George was supposed to take your lost
but he lost his silly head and shot room
after that I knew I can trust you
he had a shot everybody into the sunrise
you will be who you are crispy and oil
for horses nature keeps his original
nature in the end but haven't you heard
yourself as a father
No
I know I find you two together if I
hadn't Elsa you didn't know that
your silent friend will get the play and
you will be free to spend my money well
you weren't the only one who wants me to
die good friend the District Attorney is
just itching to oh I'll stop here and
you then do some acts of breaking glass
and shattered mirror isn't the only
point I want to stress is that it seems
to me the reason why the vs. uses this
example or refers to this film the main
reason is that mirrors are obviously
involved and that there is a very clear
visual instance of laminated field of
view the images frame and multiple--
reframed by all these mirrors seems to
give a literal literal equivalent of the
Christian image it may be too literal
are any scenes of this kinds crystal
image images is it enough to have
reflections and this kind of many at
least effects to have a crystal image
probably not and as a matter of fact the
nurse does not really elaborate on this
example because it repeatedly let's
never make something really interesting
I think anime is another of his examples
here again you have mirrors and long
tails and several operations regenerate
which kind of suggests the stratified
nature of the space-time space-time
this is what we just has to say when
they suddenly one of the author's for
whom the image is released in the
president because demons release films
our innocence
depends
junko independent family on the
coexistence of it origines durations
okay let's assume is in the complete
statement and finally another example
that I found in duders she's a person
mistake it's not very good but late
spring
this accordion according to Reuters may
be the first historically the first time
image first pure time you nation says
this can be debated but it's definitely
also an image that comes
the woman laid aside her father it's
going to be married through the club
it's important because it's also a
matter
collecting memories from the mother is
not there anymore and the nostalgia that
comes with it but what is important is
this scene which was described as still
life still not is an instance of crystal
image and why is that
why well there is never said why never
sees one there is a screen this display
of shadows
and kind of floating quality the image
but again why is this image this
particular image particularly
exemplifying the coalescence fusion of
the virtual and the actual in what sense
is this image not given in the present
as in mediocre or commercial it's not
very clear obvious and the only way if I
follow us here to actually provide
criteria rigorous application of the
concept is to rely on the front on the
fable narrative structure
it's because this family's about memory
pocket about memory and that we know
things about the characters involved in
this particular scene that we can
interpret this image as one instance of
crystal image so my suggestion is this
at this point if we don't want to overdo
or the examples of dualism entering some
kind of a game which is consistent in
well interpreting the very film's the
very example provided by the news and
long division lines which is not very
interesting yes I think we should come
up with new examples where the crystal
quality the crystalline quality of the
image is not very obvious and where we
kind of find eminent criterion for
applying the concept by eminent
criterion I mean criteria which not
solely rely on the fable on the
narrative structure the psychological
patterns which we tend to identify with
the characters imminent imminent
elements which have to do on the
contrary with the space-time structure
of the film itself and here I come back
to very good and simply to say that the
whole film is structured and I think we
reflect back on the example that just
you know this is the way we should
approach the problem of the time image
not by analyzing a single tank or a
single scene but by understanding the
structure of the whole film princess
back to the community film experience
the whole film where you go is about the
overlay or super impression of this
woman and this woman Madeline and chilly
same access Kim Novak and bobbing to
very different characters there
absolutely the opposite in every regard
and of course this is very troubling
I need sense of Masao
Dasia for texture at least and for the
spectators certainly because what
happens at the last third of the field
not really the last hot third of the
movie is that this the first character
man which was already a fiction
obviously role played by this woman this
is at least what we get from the
narrative this this woman who replaces
the this room bathroom is actually
unbelievable James to resign she is a
fraud at the same time she is kind of a
living testimony of the fact that this
woman has never died it's a very complex
the plots and a rather entangle
experience for the spectator himself
because looking at this woman cannot
stop thinking about the other woman and
sees her trace behind the
probably make up special colors and so
on yeah cinematic dish I agree which is
really your sustain until the end of the
film very when you when you think of it
this is quite rare to have this manner
of getting that this woman here which we
know is the real one is cannot be
believed
as a character even as a movie character
she's actually unbelievable and this is
what the film is about in this scene
very famous scene where James Watt asks
Shelley the second woman to dress up
like Madeline and to kind of and body or
plastic qualities what happened is
they're interesting because we have in a
way we're going to do something very
reprehensible fast-forward this scene so
you can get a sense of what happens when
she comes out of the bathroom I just
asked her to put her hair right
sorry she had to burn and the Birman was
the missing element he asked her to fix
that and when she is done this is what
you get
which I guess is goodbye five
and crystal image in the most obvious
literal sense
resurrection landing the body of jelly
or at sea quality of image of course
she's in crystal
she's all that in the same time but
my point is this
of course
it would be a rather trivial way of
identifying the crystal image of
replying division concept to movie to
suit the
sube
simply identify the fantastic quality of
the image play with colors and filters
and so on there might be something else
something deeper going on and in order
to understand this is something I've
been explaining quite extensively in my
book you have to understand that space
is involved the space not only the
narrative structure but the actual space
time of the movie itself is involved in
the process of identifying crystal
images so there are accused like junkets
even when Madeleine herself is presented
this is these are two images taken from
the scene we've seen few minutes ago the
scene in the Ernie's restaurant there is
a very strange uncle
this image is succeeded by this one well
it's not a very very clear but this is
clearly a different
lighting the overall expression maybe
even in the makeup I don't know and this
kind of substitution subtle and generous
our first cues that enable the spectator
to understand that there's something
going on which is which has to do with
the way things connect in this very
Eirias spatial temporal frame of san
francisco is never seen it before
and the conclusion I've reached by
simply reflecting on the the opening
scene credit scene
very nice the graphic animation by cell
bus is that the overall structure in
your spatial structure of the movie is
akin to the history that is the
non-orientable space the one-sided
surface which has the property of
inverting the elements that cross the
space
she's live along one of the sides in
fact there's only one side it's like I
know that one side of this twisted
silencer or a twisted strip you end up
reversed they're not really trying to
yourself which by using an L and slaying
it you'll see why come back inverted I
think the the overall structure of the
space-time is that of a non-orientable
space that the non chronological time
which relates to what I've been saying
that teacher cannot be fully understood
if you don't if you don't take into
account the non dimensional quality of
the space itself of course you could
also you could also understand this by
merely observing this very strange
curves that are that James Stewart is
tracing in San Francisco by chasing this
woman
vortex quality which ultimately leads to
the conclusion that there's no way you
can orient yourself in this place anyway
my point is that you cannot rely merely
on images even on tanks in order to
identify identify the spatial temple
structure or film and and the nature of
the crystal image crystal images as the
rotating self says it's a germs
differential element which is already
present in any image this relates to the
idea that the time image is not a
particular kind of image not a category
it's a tendency which runs through the
whole history of cinema and which is
already virtually present in every
movement image the upshot is that
there's no way you can pinpoint
particularly meant to say there you go
there it is the vortex which suggests
something that is akin to the vortex of
time and if you do that eventually you
end up playing with metaphors
so for example I think one something
that is more telling more interesting is
to reflect on the reverse belly shots
detracted very interesting tracking shot
which combines the one retracting shot
camera that has been tracked and the
optical wisdom as well the optical zoom
IAM the optical tracking shot Azumi new
zoom at the same time you have a virtual
movement virtual camera this feeling of
space and distorting itself
which is a nice illustration nice an
exemplification of the spatial temporal
ultimately spatial temporal issue and
yes well I won't really develop this
example which I have in mind which make
them for the second orientation which I
think
requires in order to know that's who
the fair which is to to take into
account the the other problem
the other issue of the coexistence of
duration in space not the coexistence of
several layers of of time within a
single direction whether the duration of
a particular scene or the duration of
the film itself of the duration the
subjective duration of the spectators
consciousness but the actual
distribution of several durations or
lines of actions if you want in a single
scene or even single moon there's this
genre cinematic zone which has something
times we call urban Symphony the
cross-section fills in Illustrator
but originally synchrony I never stopped
on Berlin or you could even think arrest
of the man
the example most recent example in my
view using real angles wanna melt
Escrima the multiscreen
seems like this one is 24
would like to say only one thing is that
of course this is the typical action
movie it's probably an instance of the
media or commercial field that's to lose
that in mind in in a sense but in
another sense it's a very remarkable
illustration of how a song which is
entirely devoted to providing effects
such as the cliffhanger or effects very
intense suspense sustained for hours
literally 24 hours how a jar which is so
clearly devoted to the most
sensory-motor
quality of cinema to use de luces
expression how is a movie of this genre
Susan this Jean can actually produce a
space-time experience to be totally I
think I would even say recalls
a nickel attack which is the experience
of a single hole of the world highly
connected most notably by the devices
which help the protagonist to
communicate at a distance using GPS cell
phones and all kinds of tracking devices
but which at the same time is totally
disruptive weight and force is really
parallel lines of patience parallel
durations or local times which
crisscross which get synchronized but
which provided experience acting
experience of the totality which is
constantly fragmenting itself sort of
imploded world including all the
catastrophe has already taken place as
you know it's really the post-september
11th movie the catastrophe has already
taken place the world is fragmented and
what
kind of splinters or laminator spare
time with things hang together quite
loosely disconnected and reconnecting
themselves in real time but of course
the whole point of the series as
explained in chapter of my book for real
time which in fact is the total fiction
which doesn't work as we think true
because there's no action at a distance
despite all the nice technologies we
have to synchronize durations principle
of the series is one of an active
disruption of durations or disconnection
that's nevertheless kind of hang
together in a fractional multiverse the
blinking fragmented world which is
probably
nice metaphor for the world
I thank you for your time
okay so we have a few minutes for
questions
they would like to start so the maybe
maybe I can ask you if if you would come
back to the question of the plot and of
narration because you mentioned
Thank You booth you're both your
examples in both your talks the point
was to extract something that wasn't
necessarily the cooperate apply it by
block right not to make narrative the
most significant part
so and not to make it certainly not
basically unity but what hang the way it
hangs together you have one good thing
can you undo a way to target with
narratives and can one do a way to tell
you with the fable or isn't I mean in
order for people to check the strength
of Jack all scales argument is that it's
precisely in these moments of tension
between a lot and of time pure
aesthetics that something happens you
see that or you I mean you both go more
towards this it seems to me in this
chronology is really trying to get away
from the movement image from pot and to
locate in modern cinema post-war said
something that's not
probably dr. Hurley Narasimha
as a matter of fact unit X example when
he's not interested
in 35
whichever say so he sees in fact the
problem is not because it is true that
is you're only relying on the top if you
will be taken
and we how can you use the cinematic
medium itself
Oh
interest
so now what concierge says
Lincoln because he says basically your
verses to the distinction between
classical Sumer and modern
gives me the time movement in the time
image and so what you want to say that
the well we have them delivered is
nothing like me it's a kind of culture
movement within the movement
and that'll cheer is true girl I think
of himself thinking gaining the case of
if you take from noon I can phone Teresa
thorry
well let let's take the all set examples
races because they weren't interesting
in victims
and if interesting these moments in
which the image is not functional in the
winter shot and our toys and there is a
little next day and nation so piece of
free movement so she is the one who's
interested in this movement which is
capable but it's not the many moments
which are temporal
we have a movement which functional
engineering but nonetheless will produce
a very strong sense of time which is
different from following the different
stations in story so that the cases
tonight
jeez about an event the problem is not
to go through the different stages of
the other interest and the question is
whether was probably meant to be an
interesting discussion to happen we can
probably say the definition of narration
on stage to another world succession
that may be wrong with the generation
Oh
the very fact that donors cannot
pinpoint Christian image with us
implicitly or explicitly relying on the
plot most yes these are the
contradictions